girls get attention everywhere but it
all depends if they entertain it all
depends on that no but listen the fact
that she's got the Instagram she's
already entertaining it and the likes
because she's got she poses she's
posting bikini pictures then yeah like
the fact that listen if it didn't matter
she would get rid of it and I'm not
saying for her to get rid of it like I
said like I said again she's your
girlfriend now if you say you want to
make into your wife here do you really
want the whole world and everybody
previously that access tutorial to still
have access to her is that something you
feel well I'm not gonna lie personally
with my when I'm with my bird she had
her profile private beautiful woman yeah
to me anyways I told her to take her
profile of private because attention is
currency right now she took her profile
of private within one month some guy in
boxed her sent her filters say take
pictures we'll send you 300 pound every
two weeks she said they sent her 300
pound over two weeks and me and her got
her eating that but this is this what
what but this is what I'm trying to tell
you she doesn't entertain it as that but
you can use it as a girls use it as a
currency attention is currency right now
okay so let me so let's as long as
you're not doing it in a flirty way
where you're like yeah sexy as long as
you're straight business because girls
can use Instagram and social media yeah
but as a dude
is it your job to protect and provide so
like why are you trying to make money
off her Instagram
I'm not trying to make money off
Instagram I'm saying if you if you have
Instagram don't put bikini pictures on
maybe use it for you know modeling or
taking selfies use it for something more
decency
the pictures if you don't mind me asking
there's no bikini pictures there's no
nothing
she's got a pretty face all she does is
takes a picture of her face and he puts
a filter whoa and that's it this is
something I can't lie bro like like this
is my levels of basically only fans it's
it's not the same but basically what
you're saying is you really wouldn't
mind your woman to set it up but only
about that because as long as men pay
for it and it's just just the face is
okay but you should be providing at a
level where no man can offer a free
bills what she's gonna take and you
shouldn't be taking that free Bill no I
think no energy to turn down 300 pounds
okay like I've been offered money for
feet picks and I turned it down because
I don't know what they're gonna do with
it that's weird and it's like it's like
if my I I always this is how I always
think about it I'm like all right if my
mom was doing this how would I feel if
my mom was selling pics I would be
embarrassed but that's feet pics pill
we're talking about a selfie
yeah but so yeah I would say something
I don't think it's insecurity it's just
wanting to protect what's yours and you
don't know what type of situation you
can be put in like you don't you don't
know she has an open Instagram Drake
could DM her you know exactly but this
is what I'm trying to say to you Jake
good DMO why if she if she entertains it
that's where the line but why would you
put her in that situation to start like
what did it like because as women we
look to men for leadership so like like
I would respect a guy more if he says
like I don't think it's a good idea for
our relationship
Instagram and she was this person why
are you gonna now come in and change her
because listen yeah okay we're talking
about I'm taking you seriously now yeah
you've been outside now and now I'm
taking you seriously right and I want to
make you into my long-term woman into my
wife what are you gonna do for me that
you haven't done for another man you're
not bringing me your Purity you're not
bringing me your your youth depending on
when you're coming so and if you're
coming with baggage and other other
stuff the one thing I ask is look babe
look just to do a clean start we're
gonna start our life you're gonna move
with me we're gonna go here can we just
leave that whole life behind us and you
cannot get rid of it it says to me you
want to be outside because at some point
you are not ready to go into the new
life you're still holding on to and what
is so good about Instagram you got a man
that's willing to take you down the
aisle willing to move in with you give
your life and you want a gram but it's
but it is circumstantial though because
the way that some of us use Instagram is
different to the way the other because
um if you say it
delete it because I don't want to give
you problem I don't want to make you
want to um like start feeling like
you're controlling me but
I go on for memes and funniness and to
keep up that's why I get reviews but you
can just do it like a profile with no
pictures yes
exactly that's what I'm saying I would
never mind go and put my Instagram on
private yeah for my partner what about
deleting it no I wouldn't delete it why
because that's
the answer is it's just that you're not
willing to really commit and you're not
really to trust in the leadership of
your partner because if you did your man
will be enough for you I don't know what
the love affair with Instagram is that
when you've got someone that's willing
to stop give your whole life and look
imagine this right you're not with the
um the father of your of your daughter
right so you meet a new man and you
already you already know how it how it
is you know being a single single mother
and dating or whatever you know so
you've got a man that wants to marry you
he wants to be a stepfather to your
child and the one the one thing he's put
down is that I just want you to get rid
of the gram and you say no yeah do you
do you think How likely do you think
hold on a second a man that wants to be
a stepfather and you know none of us
want to be stepfathers we're not rushing
we're not about me personally I don't I
don't think women with kids I just oh
it's not not something I would do
um like yeah Instagram clearly no yeah
no I could hear all of Instagram but I'm
not gonna marry a woman that has an
Instagram open to the public when I'm
ready to marry her and do all these
things
that's not an issue but even I don't
think it's that I think
it's what like for instance my sister
she has Instagram and she's
she puts quotes about the Bible that do
you have any influential thing that's
nothing nothing wrong with that is what
you use Instagram for I I've had people
contact me on Instagram that I met in
reception year one is do I mean like
people I don't know it's a nice way to
get so Instagram for you is like
Facebook for other people like I would
delete Instagram but I wouldn't delete
Facebook because Facebook is how I keep
this contact yeah but it's like those
people aren't real like how many people
do you really deal with in day-to-day
life like my dad's in the town what half
a percent of earners uh he doesn't have
any social media you don't need it and
it makes you think you have these like
connections and that like you're talking
to people you really don't the only
person that matters is your man and your
family I don't understand how a man can
be willing to be willing to marry you
and this is what I'm trying to say about
why it's not worth becoming a stepfather
because and they will move children
because you don't even understand what
he's doing you don't actually understand
you're treating him like he's any of a
guy he's willing to get married to you
become a stepfather so I'm saying to you
and you're still and it only answers for
you to come after the gram but you can't
because they're like I come off the
ground for myself no no no no no no not
for yourself when it comes to when it
comes to stepfather trust me as a mother
myself we it doesn't like we're not we
don't care about that aspect no but what
I'm trying to say to you is any man by
default becomes a stepfather so for
example if a man starts dating you right
yeah and he becomes serious about you
right yeah automatically he's a
stepfather because when he wants to come
and do something with you he has to
facilitate your daughter so for example
if he wants to buy a house right yeah he
if it was just you and him he could buy
a one bedroom or two bedroom home right
but when he has you and your daughter
he's gonna think well I need to get a
three bedroom home because we have to
have a child so automatically he's
always gonna have to do it so if you and
him have a child right and then
um
um he he
um your child wants to go to
um wants to go on holiday then he sure
wants to go on holiday but he said you
know what he's going to send his child
to to America and because it's your
child is going to send your child to
Cornwall are you going to be happy about
that if they're out if they're out at
carnival let's say for example and then
he's got your child out with his
daughter and he's got his child but his
daughter's your daughter says she wants
an an ice Pole or something he's like no
I'll call your dad and pay for it you're
going to be happy about that yeah
because what I'm trying to make you
understand is When A Man dates you he's
always going to be a stepfather in some
way whether or not it's financially or
whether or not it's just by being there
you might not classify as a stepfather
but the moment he's having to use his
resources his time his money on a child
that isn't his he's a stepfather how do
we get if I just I don't understand how
did we get to that well the the whole
point he's making is like like
relationships are about compromise and
so and so and so if he's willing to step
into that role which is really hard for
men to do because they're predisposition
to be disgusted by other people's
children the least you could do is
delete your Instagram for me as a mother
I don't I wouldn't feel comfortable in
letting any man in my life yes the
father is making a sacrifice but as a
mother myself it's hard for us to just
let a man in our house and bring a man
to our householding it right so we're
making I feel like as parents as a
mother we'll make him more of a
sacrifice because we're letting this man
um
but that's but then you should have
worked it out with the person you made a
child with but I'm saying I'm saying
like like that's just I mean I don't I
don't know your situation I don't know
you personally but I'm saying like like
that's just part of it and it's more for
a man to take on a woman's kids because
they're predisposition to be disgusted
by your children because because
historically they never wanted to pass
on resources to a kid that was not
theirs were you if he has a kid it's a
sign of pre-selection so that says The
Other Woman chose him we're attracted to
that and so it's just not a fair deal
and so when he has to take an unfair
deal where he has to take on another
band's kid it's like the least you can
do is just delete your social media
may I just say that my father had to do
that he he tried to remarry a woman
um who had a child before she came to
him and one thing that he always said to
me of the phone is absolutely it's a
great thing to be a father but being a
stepfather is a job that is thankless
with no profit it's a job that has no
profit in return
okay
I'm going to read the way you think
though what you know you don't like the
way he thinks listen listen listen this
is the thing I actually know what yeah
what don't you like huh the Instagram
bit no the Instagram bit doesn't bother
me the Instagram but it's just your
thinking of
step forward I know man wants to be me
coming into a relationship right now my
partner had a two daughters yeah it did
not affect me one bit women don't care
no let me like I actually embraced it I
looked at it as oh that would be nice
for sewing so she has because my
daughter's her only child she's like
she's 10 years old so my mindset is I'm
always looking at the benefit in that
situation I don't look at it like oh I'm
doing this child is so and so a favor
because I shouldn't have to be here
because I can find another woman that's
but don't know but that's but that's but
that's a woman's point of view yeah so
you're looking at it from a woman's
point of view right but that's because
we're attracted to a man that can take
care of other kids because one it says
to us that oh another girl selected him
that's pre-selection and the second
thing is it says oh he's gonna stick
around for my kid but with a woman it
signals to him that you're promiscuous
and that you don't make sound decisions
because you didn't get married before
you had the kid and then it's it's like
less incentive because why would he
marry you if you didn't marry the First
then I have to ask what is your baby
father do I'm not going to ask you
personally but I'm just saying so and
you know it's like like a lot of times
women be like oh the baby father was a
waste man they won't like the baby if
I'm gonna talk badly but I think but
then I'll look at myself and they'll be
like damn I actually thought he was nice
and all of a sudden when I see who they
chose to to to breed with I'm like no
actually no you're looking like a
wastegirl because I was rating you I had
you on a pedest German skills I put on a
pedestal and they didn't realize they
were actually on a pedestal then you
look at the choices they made you're
like damn is that what you chose it's
something else that I've heard from
other men why would other men have said
to me why would I want to raise another
man's inferior DNA if you chose this man
to if you chose this manner you're
saying he's such a waste man right why
would I want to come into this situation
and raise DNA that I now will consider
in inferior because you're telling me
how much oh let me do an extreme one I
know it's like slightly extreme but I
want to use it as something and let's
say I love a child I bring this child as
my own like a raise this child this
child gets really old and the child gets
sick the child needs a blood transfusion
on the kidney I I'm the father this
child he calls me his father the child
looks at me as the dad but at this
moment I cannot save my child at this
moment we need to find a real dad and in
this moment I realized that all this
time I've just been playing and acting
like it let's let's let's flip it around
now I'm sick I'm dying now yeah and this
child I've raised now loves me as a
father he's watching me die he wants to
give me something he can't give me
nothing at that point you realize that
whole thing everything you did was a
waste of time and I'm not trying to but
I'm trying to show you the extreme of
you might need to give your child
something in the future and you cannot
do it men are not supposed to be coming
and doing something else and you gave
the highest honor to another man and now
you're out here be like you know what
I'm a single mother doesn't affect me it
does affect you I never said I was a
singer on my phone no but are you
married huh
unless you're married you're a single
mother like essentially I don't I don't
consider myself yes technically I'm a
single woman but I've never considered
myself as a single mother at the point
you broke up like the stigma behind
single models for me it's just it's not
the same it's not it's not a stigma and
this is the problem right we we get told
as men that having a standard I'm I'm
now being told I'm bad for having a
standard for not actually wanting to
have a single mother like there's
nothing wrong with you as a person
you're actually a cool person but the
fact remains yeah the type of woman I
want is a woman especially if you are a
single mom I would have hoped you got
married is your husband did he die what
really happened was you in abuse if it
was just a fact that I picked the wrong
guy and I and I bread from him do you
know how in my mind I just speak to
myself that is such bad decision making
because you didn't even require a ring
you just let any man literally bust in
there and say yo this is what it is do
you have any kids I don't have no kids
no yeah it's when you have kids
as many of you know I was just banned on
tick tock talk and we are demonetized on
a daily basis on this platform if you
want to help please consider sending a
super thanks below every donation helps
and it helps make what we do possible